will do in my part of the presentation
is briefly giving you the background of
metagenomics
and kind of
following
some of the resources that you will also
find in the introductory materials on
the learn portal for anyone who would
like to kind of get familiar with these
concepts before we start the program
uh so you know i want to kind of start
from the very beginning and talk a
little bit about
you know why
the microbiome
how exactly can we study the microbiome
so since the discovery of the microscope
we've been learning about microorganisms
that surround us and even live inside us
and with the increasing resolution so
here we have a chart of the
different types of
small
things that you can see in the
microscope
you can see that the optical microscopy
resolution allows us to see kind of all
the way to
bacteria and because of that
this kind of interest in the way that
this micro
the micro organisms live together
has evolved as the resolution allowed us
to see small and smaller things so what
you can see here on the bottom
is a
figure this is an image from a
microscope a
super high resolution microscope where
you can see e coli and some phages so
these are viruses that
are sitting on the e coli bacteria so
what has been has become clear with the
increasing resolution is that not only
that there are trillions of
microorganisms around us they also live
in communities and they interact with
each other not just with their hosts or
the environment
so um
because of that uh early on there has
been an acknowledgment of the role that
the microbes play in human health and
well-being
and uh early on you can see here in the
mid 1600s there was the first
observation of microscopic organism and
by the 1800s there has been an
association made between disease and
microorganisms but today um in the last
couple of decades there has been a
tremendous increase in research
concerning the role of the microbiome in
a variety of different conditions that
affect the environment but also affect
us as people including different aspects
of human health and development
of the healthy microbiome on the skin
in the gut and in other organs
and what we will talk about today are
several examples
just to kind of understand
uh what are some of the considerations
you know how is the microbiome studied
what are some technologies that have
been used do that
how these technologies are evolving and
what we will cover in the program to be
able to handle such data practically and
and kind of understand the insights that
we can gain from
such data
so
one important factor about the
microbiome is the stability so
essentially
these communities of bacteria
specifically will talk more about the
bacteria rather than just the whole
microbiome
we can kind of all relate to the
stability of these communities when we
think about
such
microbiome communities like our skin
so for example
microbiome on the skin
will create a biofilm
and this biofilm can actually
communicate with each other by producing
detecting and responding to small
diffusible signal molecules
in a process called quorum sensing which
can first confer benefit for host
colonization biofuel information defense
against competitors and adaptation to
changes in the environment and quorum
sensing activities
are also involved in the violence and
pathogenic potential of bacteria and so
they're an important factor in
understanding and controlling bacteria
and bacterial infections as they enable
microorganisms in biofilms to become
more tolerant of host defenses and
anti-microbial agents and inside each
community there is going to be a balance
of bacteria fungi and viruses that
control species abundance in skin so if
you touch your own skin
uh you will feel that there is more than
just um
you know one type of feeling on your
skin right some
parts of your skin might be dry some of
them might be oily some of them might
feel smooth or or might have bumps on
them so all of this means that there's
this whole microbiome interacting with
the host and
one question that we might have is well
what factors are actually determining
some of the
qualities of this microbiome how are
these distinct communities different
from each other
because we know that all of our skins
are probably very different from each
other but also how uh do the things that
we can control affect
these communities and so to answer some
of these questions
there has been a tremendous interest in
understanding characterization
and uh you know investigation of the
factors that really control the
microbial communities in many different
organs so you can see here on the screen
some of those um
defined microbiomes like the microbiome
of the skin the respiratory system the
gut the intestines the stomach
the urogenital tract
so all of these um since uh
2010 i believe there have been hundreds
of thousands of papers um related uh to
the microbiome and major projects that
have been developed so some of the major
projects that you can see right here in
2010 we have the human microbiome
project that we will talk a lot about
in this program but also throughout the
years there have been distinct projects
focused on the gut
skin lung and even brain microbiomes
so many of these projects like the human
microbiome project seem
uh
seek to
characterize the healthy microbiome
because there's a lot of variation as we
already discussed and we'll talk about
in in a few slides
related to the age to the location
to the diet and lifestyle as well as the
environment of the healthy microbiome
but then also an additional set of
projects have been designed to address
some of the questions around disease so
you can see here cancer prevention study
for microbiome in cancer
you can see the alzheimer's gut
microbiome project the nurses health
study and others and so
really we can see here a variety of
disciplines that will be affected by the
microbiome from healthy nutrition and
lifestyle all the way to a variety of
precision medicine applications and even
you can see here on the bottom
space travel right so it
appears to also play a role
in space uh travel and the health of
astronauts and so many different areas
of application for metagenomics and for
microbiome
so
because of all of these projects we know
today that the human microbial
communities contribute to
many critical and essential metabolic
physiological and immunological
functions
and they include differentiation and
maturation of the host mucosa and its
immune system food digestion and
nutrition energy generation metabolic
regulation and control of fat storage
processing and detoxification of
environmental chemicals maintenance of
skin and mucosal barrier function
development and regulation of the immune
system prevention of invasion and growth
of disease promoting microorganisms
and several others and so to study
these conditions and this variability
there are several different types of
omics technologies to study the
microbiome and these could be
distinguished into uh sequencing based
or mass spectrometry based so for
sequencing we can look at
the dna based approaches so essentially
we can sequence
specific genes or try to assemble whole
genomes of
bacteria or whatever species of these
microorganisms
we can also look at rna based so we can
try to infer function what are some of
the genes that are being expressed
and and what do they mean what is their
function
there are also ways to study uh the
microbiome using mass spectrometry where
we can look at proteins and metabolites
that they produce
but today in in this session we'll talk
a little bit more in detail about
metagenomic sequencing
and so metagenomic sequencing
uh metagenomics in general could be
characterized as both a field and a
specific technique
to study the microbiome
but it is different from many other
types of omics so essentially many types
of omics
are focused on characterizing a single
system a single
individual for example when we speak
about the genomic studies we're trying
to understand the genome of an
individual
metagenomics in that sense is different
because it looks at a community so
specifically
when we speak about a community we think
of the microbiome as almost like an
organ that has a specific function
and
one of the ways that we want to
understand the function of this organ is
by capturing the diversity of
microorganism within that microbiome or
microbiota the community that it forms
and when we do that it is different from
a lab-based technique where essentially
a single
microorganism is isolated and is grown
in a different environment than where it
actually
typically lives and so because only one
to two percent of bacteria can be
cultured in the lab
metagenomics allows us to study
how these microorganisms coexist
together with others and respond
together to different environmental
changes or produce some functional
effects
so the
difference between these two
we can see here
for
for example when we want to study the
gut microbiome
one of the ways that we can use
sequencing to understand this microbial
community is by trying to annotate the
different taxonomic variation uh found
within the gut
and sometimes we can also combine that
with an understanding of a particular
individual
of a representative of that community to
try to understand what is that specific
individual bacteria for example how is
it different from others right so we'll
talk a little bit about how these
techniques could be applied to different
types of conditions in just a moment but
let's try to see how this type of
information could be generated and what
are some of the techniques to then study
the data that is being generated from
sequencing
so two kind of approaches that i want to
discuss here the first one is sequence
based when we are able to sequence
all of the dna or the rna that is
present in a sample like next generation
sequencing
so this could be shotgun metagenomics
uh 16s amplicon metagenomics or meta
transcriptomics
and then sometimes we also have these
approaches with qpcr when we know
that we're looking for specific types of
bacteria and we could design primers to
actually
find whether there is an abundance of a
particular type of a bacteria or
combinations of bacteria so if you think
about
the
next few slides you'll see how both of
these could probably be applied to
answer similar questions but will more
speak about next generation sequencing
because of the richness of information
that it can provide us with and
how we can apply qbcr for example to
validate the findings that we will see
in next generation sequencing so really
shot can manage genomics or meta
transcriptomics differs from 16s
amplicon metagenomics in the way that
we're able to capture the specific
view of the composition of the microbial
community using 16s amplicon
metagenomics or essentially thinking
about the 16s ribosomal rna as a marker
gene that helps us understand taxonomy
and then shotgun metagenomics or
metatranscriptomics is the analysis of
all of the genes within an ecosystem so
the difference is are we sequencing all
of the genes or all of the gene known or
are we looking at conserved marker genes
or gene regions
and some of the challenges that are
associated with both of these approaches
so first of all in
trying to
sequence all of the data that is present
in the dna that we extract from this
microbial community obviously assembly
is going to be one of the major
challenges how do you take these short
reads and try to piece them together to
extend them into an assembled genome or
at least a part of the genome that then
we can search for specific genes and try
to annotate them so even with 16s
amplicon sequencing we have this
challenge of annotation as well because
essentially
not all of the bacterial genomes are
known but because we have databases that
are constantly being updated and because
of these major studies it is possible to
define the taxonomy or the diversity and
the presence or absence of specific
types of bacteria in a given sample
so let's uh kind of talk about 16s
metagenomic sequencing and uh try to
understand the specific applications of
16s metagenomic sequencing which i think
are
very exciting in the context of
human health and well-being different
types of disease applications and even
behavior as we will see
so 16s amplicon sequencing is a
technique that is widely used
one of the most
kind of widely used techniques
and this sequencing focuses focuses on
the 16s ribosomal rna gene so first that
gene is amplified with pcr amplification
and that gene contains hypervariable
regions that allow us to study taxonomy
of a particular community so one of the
challenges with the actual sequencing is
first to organize the sequences that we
get into what we call operational
taxonomic units and these are units that
resemble each other with some specific
markers
and then we can use those to annotate
and try to understand
what do they match in a database
and so there are several different
databases like the silva
green genes
there's the ncbi
repository of all of the bacterial
genomes
and as well as rdp so what do these
databases essentially provide us with
so these databases can help us
understand taxonomy or
if we think about the hierarchy of
biological classification
how we can study
the
more or less detailed view of the
different types of organisms so the
taxonomy is just a way to organize the
different types of organisms into some
kind of a structure so we can see what
is more related or less related so
starting from the bottom here kingdom
phylum class order family genus and all
the way to species now as you will see
not all of these are going to be
available for all of the individual
microbial organisms that we will have
and so what
what we can try to assess
are the differences at maybe
specific levels like for example class
phylum or order or sometimes dig deeper
into the species level of classification
so to really understand how diverse the
microbiome is
and how many organisms organisms we're
dealing with let's actually look at the
silva database and we'll see there how
how many different organisms organisms
you are going to be finding there so i'm
going to paste the link
in the chat box and i will actually
address your questions here in a few
minutes
so
please go with me to this link
okay so
this is
the database
the silva database
here you will find
the
different levels
so right here you can see those levels
domain phylum family major clade class
genus kingdom and order and so you can
see here
bacteria right that's the kingdom and
then it goes all the way down to family
right here
so what you can do here is you can
search by sequences
by accession number or by full name
and here you will
be able to find by taxon name or you can
also
browse here specific types of bacteria
so
as we go through i will give a couple of
examples
of bacteria that you will be able to
find here
and
search for it right here in the taxon
name and then you'll be able to find it
okay
beyond the bacteria right what we need
to remember is that a microbiome
contains also
uh viruses um as well as
other microorganisms so
because
we have this interaction between
bacteria the community that it forms and
other microorganisms right we won't talk
about it as much today but you have to
remember that
the same
types of databases exist for
other
microorganisms that you might expect to
find in the microbiome
um so again viruses for example
as well as you can see here the the
virum right so in the same way that we
can call the microbiome all of the
microorganisms we can also look at
specific
types of
microorganisms so for example for
viruses as well called the viral